as far as me give advice before I
started filming I got two pieces one was
don't get drunk and don't trust anyone
and I totally mess those up within the
first 10 minutes I got drunk and I like
trusted everyone meet your new OC
housewife Bronwyn or number you throw me
to a group of women with music and
tequila and I am going to have a good
time
I mean I have seven kids so you get me a
babysitter and take me out of my house
I'm gonna make the most of it and these
were fun I mean they know how to have a
good time and I just instantly had a
connection with with all of them did you
watch the show before you signed up for
the show I did I was a big fan and I'm
watching the whole time so for me it was
sort of like you know a dream come true
almost is it weird to step into this
having watched it on TV and now like
you're this close to Vicki Gunvalson it
wasn't first but the women are also
authentic and they're also real that
very quickly they go from being people
you've seen on the screen to actual
women that you have relationships with
these are your real friends now I have
relationships with all of them some of
them are my real friends some of them
are you know just really great people I
want to get your first impression of
each of your new pals
so Kelly Kelly is fun I mean the two of
us together was like freaking frack we
had the best time doesn't matter what we
were doing it was fun
we just mesh well together our energies
are very similar Tamra she's like a soul
sister I mean she's my partner in crime
I love her we just we kind of had that
little naughty side to us and we have a
lot of fun together Shannon has a huge
heart
she opened you know she welcomes me with
open arms I adore her jeana's kind of
like the little sister you know of the
group I feel like and and then Anne was
kind of the big sister you know when
we're we're all making some bad choices
she's like a
everyone you know keep it together and
then you know Vicki she's like the
principal or the mom sort of speak you
know she's the og of the OC have you
card the principal did you get called to
the principal's office this season maybe
I have not revealed all what I know once
the show starts there will likely be
some criticism that you took Vicki spot
yes I think when people watch they're
gonna realize that's not true
Vicki's she's with us all the time she's
on the trip she still films with us
Vicki is a big part of this show this
season walking away from the season you
said some of these girls are your real
true friends now who do you count as a
real true friend today I love Shannon we
live in the same town I see her when we
go out all the time I run into Kelly and
Shannon just in our day to day lives
Tamra I don't see her as much we're both
very busy but I text her all the time
for advice because she's been really
helpful to me so those are the ones I'm
the closest to now housewives is kind of
a sorority you're a part of this whole
world now of women across the country
who hold this title and I know you've
gotten friendly with like D'Andra from
Dallas and met some of those ladies have
you seen the comparisons to you and
Stephanie whole net from Dallas I have
and I actually thought it was so funny I
got out my original cover of Sweet
Valley High and I'm like she gets to be
Elizabeth and I'll be Jessica
[Laughter]
it's Stephanie Holman I love that people
think we look so much alike I just want
to wish you the most incredible first
season soak it all up because it is
truly a magical time oh my god she's so
sweet I mean you guys really do I
thought I was joking but we do it's like
Jessica Elizabeth the Wakefield twins I
got to get together I'm actually
planning a trip to Dallas this summer
all right as soon as he under gets her
boot off I'm going out there to visit
but before she heads to Dallas Bronwyn
will head to your TV screen making her
our hoc debut in the season 14 premiere
on August 6th
going into this what do you want viewers
to know about you what do they need to
know about God I think for me one of the
big reasons I did the show was because
it's important to say yes I have seven
kids I'm a full-time mom but it's also I
have another side to me and that's okay
I'm also sometimes just Bronwen let's
talk about seven kids yeah that's a lot
of kids that's a lot of kids why seven
originally we wanted five from the first
time I met my husband I always wanted to
be a stay-at-home mom with a lot of kids
that was sort of my dream and then I
don't know after the boys were born four
and five were twins
I kind of it was like someone's missing
I didn't feel that feeling of being done
so we went first six and we ended up
losing one of the twins we twins again
and losing one so we went for a seventh
because I I sort of felt like we needed
to end on a high note and that someone
else was supposed to be there so we had
our seventh
I felt done so we didn't really go into
it thinking seven it just it was just
the right number it evolved it did but
now I look at the family photo I'm like
everyone that's supposed to be here is
here in the premiere you say you've been
breastfeeding for 18
that is a true statement that's a wild
statement brought oh yeah yeah that's
crazy isn't it
are you still breastfeeding now no okay
we are done locked up I I went out with
a bang I am no longer nursing and I am
living like my best life ever
when we speak out loud we actually learn
from one another you vote how would you
sum up this season in a couple words how
would you describe your experience it
was the best time I've ever had in my
life
it was not just fun but I also learned a
lot about myself I learned a lot about
relationships between women I learned
how to step out of my comfort zone and I
learned that I'm not always right okay
that's a big big life that's nothing as
a fan of the show if you had to kind of
rate this on a scale of one to ten
what's this season oh this is a ten I
mean I'm I'm there and I I mean I looked
in my photos even I'm sometimes like I
can't believe that happened
you know you joke about it but you
couldn't script this stuff you know it
is it is a good season
[Music]
[Applause]
[Music]